bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo en compagnie de
mickaël zeze bonjour miquel dans
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine il ya évidemment le
remaniement existe deux poids lourds
michèle alliot marie et brice hortefeux
arrivée de deux nouveaux claude guéant
et gérard longuet alors qu'alain juppé
devient l'homme fort aux commandes du
quai d'orsay
quand le débat sur l'islam voulu par
l'ump devient débat sur la laïcité
changement d'appellation qui montre
l'embarras de la droite sur une
initiative controversée
le patron de l'ump jean françois copé
persiste et signe le débat aura bien
lieu le 5 avril prochain lors d'une
convention du parti
enfin françois fillon sonne le glas du
bouclier fiscal ce dispositif symboles
du quinquennat sarkozy disparaîtra dès
la prochaine loi de finances un peu
d'argent pour les caisses de l'état qui
devrait financer en contrepartie un
aménagement de l'impôt sur la fortune
est avec nous autres plateaux notre
invité chantal jouanno bonjour ministre
des sports depuis novembre 2010 un
domaine que vous connaissez bien car
vous avez pratiqué le haut niveau le
karaté c'est votre discipline
douze fois championne de coupe de france
12 titres de championne de france
de quoi peut-être calmer les ardeurs de
vos ennemis mais peut-être aussi de vos
amis et parce qu'il en faut peut-être
aussi en politique c'est très important
pour calmer un petit peu tout le monde
est votre deuxième phase est bien sûr
c'est l'écologie tout le monde le sait
vous en avez été là secrétaire d'état
pendant près de deux ans les écologistes
qui ont souvent la dent dure
reconnaissent vos compétences et vos
convictions en la matière conviction qui
vous ont même mené jusqu'à fâché en plus
haut lieu lorsque vous alliez protester
ouvertement contre l'abandon de la taxe
carbone vous en souvenez sûrement oui le
ministère des sports on vous autant un
petit peu moins seriez vous un peu à
l'étroit dans ce ministère
on m'a entendu sur la défense des
valeurs du sport
assez assez clairement non cela
ministère qui est intéressant parce que
on touche à tous les aspects de la
société on touche aux aspects
d'éducation bien évidemment on touche à
la vie collective le sport assad
intéressant qu'il rassemble dans un
vestiaire où autour d'un stade dé
personnes quel que soit leur niveau de
revenu
leurs origines leurs convictions c'est
il ya très peu de lieux aujourd'hui dans
notre pays dans les pays développés qui
rassemble et le sport en fait partie
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut pas laisser
le sport se laisser pervertir par
d'autres valeurs et notamment des excès
d'argent ou confondre le sport le
spectacle et puis ça veut dire aussi
qu'il faut prendre le flambeau pour
défendre des valeurs éducatives du sport
votre et la pratique de son passé de
sportif de haut niveau vous aide
c'est alors c'est un petit plus mais
c'est pas la condition pour être
ministre des sports ça reste un domaine
qui est très technique et par exemple
marie george buffet a toujours été fan à
la réputation et a été une très grande
ministre des sports elle n'était pas
sportive elle l'a très bien assumé mais
elle s'est plongée dans les dossiers
notamment dans la lutte contre le dopage
la pratique du sport à haut niveau ça
ceci d'intéressant que on a partagé avec
des sportifs de haut niveau un peu ce
qu'ils ont vécu
je pas le niveau des champions
olympiques loin de là mais vous remonter
à loin marie george buffet vous le
bateau n'était pas une sportive de
l'université on peut en citer en citer
d'autres simplement c'est bien aussi de
montrer la diversité du panel politique
on va passer au reste de l'actualité
cette semaine évidemment c'était marqué
par le changement ce remaniement au
gouvernement
dans une intervention à la télévision
nicolas sarkozy s'est expliqué sur ses
choix
la voix de la france à l'étranger ne
porte plus il fallait donc changer de
tête
alain juppé remplace michèle alliot
marie qui suivit peut être les
conséquences de son voyage privé en
tunisie
nicolas sarkozy en a profité également
pour de cette séquence pour faire des
ajustements au sein de son gouvernement
et pas des moindres eléonore picot nous
avons décidé de réorganiser les
ministères qui concernent notre
diplomatie et notre sécurité
ainsi les fonctions régaliennes de
l'état se trouveront-elles préparées à
affronter les événements à venir dont
nul ne peut prévoir le déroulement
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est une nouvelle
étape qui sauf pour m'engager de manière
renouvelée personnelle indéfectible et
forte aux côtés du président de la
république pour servir
je mesure bien que ce que certains belle
mon retour à la maison comporte
d'honneur et en même temps de charge de
responsabilités
j'ai passé ici un peu plus de 100 jours
qui m'ont profondément marqué je suis un
peu triste de vous quitter je lui ai dit
tout à l'heure je suis heureux d'aller
assumer la responsabilité que le
président de la république et au
ministre de le confier
mais ce qui atténue la tristesse c'est
que je suis sûr que je voulais sans
d'excellentes mains gérard longuet est
un ami depuis longtemps c'est un immense
bonheur que de servir son pays dans
cette responsabilité si particulière de
ministre de la défense on sert alain
vous retrouvez une maison que vous avez
connu il y à une quinzaine d'années et
dans laquelle vous m'avez dit un jour
que vous aviez été très heureux je vous
souhaite de l'être à nouveau pleinement
dans ses fonctions je suis assez bien
placé pour savoir que la vie politique
est parfois brutale et injuste
je suis aussi aujourd'hui placé pour
savoir que la roue tourne et je vous
souhaite à vous aussi
ma chère michèle bon vent et bonne mer
chantal jouanno quand on entend michèle
alliot marie
bon vent bonne mère elle devait partir
michèle alliot marie s'était devenait
inéluctable
déjà je pense qu'il est important de
rappeler un principe c'est qu'il ya qu
une personne élue au gouvernement c'est
le président de la république qu aucun
ministre n'est titulaire de son poste
aucun si demain le président veut
remplacer par quelqu'un d'autre je n'ai
rien à dire et c'est pas une question de
justice ou d'injustice
on travaille dans le sens de l'intérêt
général point là on n'a que des devoirs
quand on est ministre vraiment que des
devoirs
après ce qui devenait ce qui était
délicat michèle alliot marie n'a rien
commis d'illégal rien et c'est important
de le rappeler mais et il lui était
devenu très difficile d'aller dans les
pays arabes qui ont assez mal vécu
ensuite les certaines déclarations
donc le président de la république de
toute façon
avec des chats est finalement c'était la
voix de la sagesse était inévitable de
remplacer michèle alliot-marie par alain
juppé qui est un homme expérimenté très
expérimenté dans ce domaine très reconnu
dans le domaine des affaires étrangères
maintenant c'est c'est la brutalité de
la politique ça c'est très clair
ces taxis extrêmement stoïque vous qui
connaissez les miss à la casquette
vissée sur la tête
alors elle est très c'est une femme
d'état très expérimenté donc elle sait
aussi effectivement que c'est la logique
c'est la loi du système
qu'est ce qui passe par la tête
c'est très difficile parce que on a beau
savoir qu'on est là que de passage
on s'attache on s'attache aux personnes
on s'attache au sujet et même quand tu
parti de l'écologie pour aller au sport
honnêtement c'est lourd et je pense que
pour michel c'était encore plus lourd
sera jouanno ce remaniement est ce que
vous l'avez senti comme un signe de
fébrilité de la part du président de la
république tiff
on a l'impression a été presque obligé
de remanier on ne lit jamais obligé de
remanier ou c'est le mot populaire la
pression président de la république pour
bien connaître n'est pas un homme
fébrile c'est pas c'est pas son
qualificatif
c'était nécessaire de le faire
simplement parce que c'est dans
l'intérêt général du pays
donc il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas
se poser de question et il lui doit
mettre de côté ses sentiments quel qu'il
soit pour être dans le sens de l'intérêt
général donc
et puisque je parlais de fébrilité parce
que l'opposition a parlé de fébrilité
c'est toujours très marrant parce que il
demandait le remaniement une fois qu'ils
ont ils n'en veulent plus c'est toujours
assez mais ça sérieux de la politique
français à se séparer aussi d'un ami
brice hortefeux notamment balsan séparés
entre guillemets puisque brice mais aux
services officiels et brice hortefeux a
toujours dit au président d'un public ce
sont quand même des amis qu' il ferait
ce que le président souhaitera mais
brice est vraiment bon c'est quelqu'un
de bien
c'est vraiment quelqu'un de bien
d'accord je sais que ça blague entre
guillemets n'était pas bonne
il le paye bon la condamnation on va
voir effectivement je pensais pas juste
de juger c'était vraiment une mauvaise
blague on sait quand on est femme
politique ont été condamnés après quand
on est femme ou homme politique on sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui plus qu'hier
rien ne passe rien ne passe et on est
totalement transparent il ya plus de
distinction entre notre vie privée et
notre vie publique
tout ce que je demande moi c'est que
l'on touche pas aux familles vous vous
disiez que nicolas sarkozy n'était pas
contraint il a quand même classé plier
aux conditions imposées par alain juppé
au quai d'orsay en faisant son le
dialogue entre c'est entre ces deux
hommes
ça c'est je rentre pas dans le dernier
puisque je connais pas l'intimité de
leur dialogue
honnêtement mais mais à la jupe est de
toute façon et quand même quelqu'un très
reconnue au quai d'orsay et qui a il a
pris beaucoup de recul
il était obligé donc il a pris beaucoup
de recul par rapport à la à la politique
et il est très respecté au quai dans
votre question quels seront les rapports
au sein du gouvernement entre 1 alain
juppé entrée par la grande porte et son
premier ministre
il y a eu en début de semaine ce petit
échange entre les deux hommes par médias
interposés que l'on pourrait peut-être
qualifiée d' aigre douce on écoute fait
étrangère il est incontestable que c'est
un poste qui par les déplacements qu'il
impose sera en sorte qu'il sera moins
présent à bordeaux il n'y a aucune règle
qui interdisent à un ministre d'exercer
un mandat local et le nombre de mes
collègues qui se trouvent dans cette
situation est considérable y compris
derrière le premier ministre qui doit
toujours être président d'une communauté
de communes dans la sarthe
si je suis bien informé le jour où la
loi changera bien entendu je me
conformerai et je peux vous dire que
dans cette hypothèse là où dans cette
circonstance là je choisirais bourbourg
alors ça sonne un peu comme j'ai pas de
leçon à recevoir d'un homme qui préside
une communauté de communes ça commence
pas très bien honnêtement c'est parce
que vous avez envie de le lire comme ça
parce que honnêtement
non mais l'un et l'autre ils disent ils
disent des choses justes il n'y a pas
d'obligation de quitter son mandat de
maire d'un côté et c'est évident qu'il
sera moins présent à bordeaux de l'autre
donc je pense que les deux ne pouvait
pas répondre autre chose en réalité
c'est ça s'est débarrassé des petits
problèmes après il ya un vrai sujet sur
lequel la question du cumul des mandats
qui est un sujet de fond c'est un autre
un autre sujet mais on est en moi depuis
le début je n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas eu
de tension entre ces deux hommes
ce sont deux très grosses pointures
comme on dit en politique deux hommes
qui ont des convictions politiques
deux hommes qui s'expriment librement
problèmes d'ego entre ces deux personnes
on me tous les tous les politiques ont
sans doute des problèmes de vaud on va
pas se voiler la face
bon mais il ya une hiérarchie dans
gouvernement personne ne la conteste
on dit que perso fillon a raté le coche
à n'a pas réussi à s'imposer après le
remaniement de la fin de l'année
dernière comment ça peut s'expliquer bah
on disait avant qu'il prenait trop de
place qu'il était incontournable
maintenant dit que il a raté au culot
raté le coche
françois fillon n'a pas changé d'un iota
sa manière de faire et sa manière d'être
le premier ministre pas d'un iota
il est il est au front sur la question
de la de la fiscalité sur les questions
aux affaires étrangères ça a toujours
été de toute façon le domaine du
président de la république penser qu'il
se réjouit de ce remaniement il a quand
même un alain juppé homme fort du
gouvernement à claude guéant avec il
s'est semble-t-il pas toujours très bien
entendus 1 gérard longuet qui est très
indépendant c'est en tout cas sa
réputation
enfin je pense que plus on a une équipe
d'hommes ou de femmes de femmes et
d'hommes avec du caractère
mais avec du caractère et expérimentés
mieux c'est après ça peut ne s'applique
pas mais mieux c'est et j'ai toujours
tendance à dire que plus on est fort
plus on est ouvert a justement cette
concurrence et 7 on a besoin aujourd'hui
d'avoir des forts caractères des forts
tempéraments des personnes expérimentées
à la tête de notre pays et consignes
ray qu'on doit avoir qu'une équipe bien
soumise sous ses ordres et avec des
petits caractères je trouve que c'est
vraiment c'est une attitude de me fait
donc je pense vraiment qu'il ya pas de
difficultés pour françois fillon
vous avez toujours l'intention de
composer un ticket avec françois fillon
pour la mairie de paris en 2014 et j'ai
toujours l'intention enfin je pense
toujours que c'est le meilleur homme
pour venir à paris
aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans le contexte actuel c'est meilleur
homme pour venir à paris parce que on a
besoin d'un homme d'état si on souhaite
que la droite gagner la mairie de paris
parce qu'il peut incarner justement tous
ces grands projets qui autour de paris
et notamment le grand paris et parce que
vous avez vous aviez caché un peu
rachida dati avec cette phrase sur on a
besoin d'un homme d'état oui mais
tellement impersonnel mais c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas mon sujet rachida
toumaï la question c'est d'avoir toutes
les bonnes volontés et justement ce que
je vous disais auparavant
on a besoin d'avoir des personnes qui
sont qui sont fortes qui sont
effectivement des personnes avec des des
caractères qui sont des individualités
mais on a besoin et plus on a à paris
mieux c'est le vrai sujet c'est celui là
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on veut ou non
proposer quelque chose de nouveau à
paris est ce que l'on gagne et paris
donc je pense que françois est un
candidat adéquat
moi j aime travailler sur le fond ça a
toujours été mon truc on dit parfois que
je suis très scolaire d'ailleurs mais
donc travaillé sur le projet oui ça
m'intéresse pour proposer quelque chose
avec jeu c'est une personnalité et des
orientations politiques qui sont parfois
un peu décalé bon c'est pas grave
une autre personnalité qui a du poids
c'est claude guéant c'est un homme qui
incarne naturellement l'ordre dit de lui
nicolas sarkozy
coup de coeur on vous l'avait bien connu
il a fait ses premiers pas comme
ministre de l'intérieur et à peine
arrivé déjà lancés dans l'arène des
questions au gouvernement
écoutez ce commentaire à la sortie il
n'a pas fait tous les cheminements
beaucoup d'élus ici à l'assemblée
nationale commencé par un simple mandat
de conseiller municipal conseiller
général maire député lui c'est un
fonctionnaire un haut fonctionnaire un
préfet savait pas dire c'est pas
quelqu'un de qualité
aucun intelligent mais c'est une épreuve
de passer devant l'assemblée nationale
il est loin comme est rare maladresse ah
non il était simplement tendu stressé
claude guerre où vous l'avez bien connu
vous étiez avec lui en 2002 au ministère
de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui la gauche vous l'avez
entendu dit de lui que ce n'est pas un
élu il va avoir du mal à être une
personnalité politique qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous claudio sais c'est
un peu mon mentor c'est un homme que
j'admire vraiment par ses qualités
intellectuelles et par son caractère
parce qu'il a un coeur énorme
il l'a reconnu lui-même d'ailleurs dès
la première réunion du groupe ump qui
l'avait plus de devoirs que les autres
ministres comme moi j'en ai plus que les
autres ministres parce que on est pas
passé enfin je suis passé entre temps
mais on n'est pas passé par l'onction du
suffrage universel et ses principes de
la démocratie de votre saison 2 au
dessus du suffrage universel mais comme
gut était tous les autres ministres
avant de passer par le suffrage
universel de ligue 1 et que tous étaient
donc ça il a reconnu et c'est pas une
question qu'il a nié quant au fait de
savoir si les stresse et surtout pour
son baptême du feu de répondre à ce
qu'on appelle les questions d'actualité
mais c'est évident c'est pas simple tout
est mené la première fois c'était
difficile évidemment et tous les
ministres même les plus expérimentés
sont stressés tendue quand on répond à
des questions d'actualité parce que ça a
l'air calme quand on voit à la télé mais
c'est très agitée il ya des petits noms
d'oiseaux qui vole ses temps on est
quand même au coeur de l'arène
et puis c'est vraiment un exercice
particulier très contraint encore un mot
son club il incarne l'ordre la reprise
en main du ministère notamment sur
l'immigration et la sécurité vous pensez
que c'est une reprise en main après le
passage de brice hortefeux brice alors
sagem ont dû fait toujours des procès en
attention la délinquance a reculé avec
brice comme elle a reculé
d'ailleurs depuis 2002 donc la
délinquance a reculé
évidemment on a un gros problème sur la
question des violences aux personnes
malheureusement les autres pays
européens malheureusement dire qu'on est
sur un problème de civilisation qu'un
problème lourd maintenant claude guillon
c'est l'eau il l'a dit lui-même c'est le
retour à la maison parce que c'est un
homme du ministère de l'intérieur qui en
connaît toutes les arcanes qui était
bras droit du président de la république
notamment quand de 2002 à 2004 on a mis
en place beaucoup de réformes sur les
fameux jir vous savez pour rassembler
les compétences sur les grosses affaires
donc c'est il le connaît il le connaît
par coeur et c'est un homme qui a un
caractère très fort donc il l'exercera
avec son style c'est certain et un style
connais bien aussi qu'un ministère dont
il connaît toutes les arcanes et il est
il exercera avec sa sérénité
avec son style vois que vous appréciez
beaucoup le personnage complet chantal
jouanno on va dire aussi un mot de
gérard longuet nouveau ministre de la
défense son dernier portefeuille remonte
à 17 ans il était ministre de
l'industrie d'edouard balladur et là
dedans vous le voyez retrouvé cette
semaine le chemin du conseil des
ministres et à peine nommé déjà un
avocat celui des parties civiles dans la
sphère de l'attentât de karachi
demandent à ce qu'il soit entendu sur le
financement de la campagne d'edouard
balladur en 95
est ce que nicolas sarkozy ne prend pas
un peu un risque de nouvelle polémique
avec il agira en longuet a été écarté de
la vie politique pendant très très
longtemps et ça s'est soldée par un
non-lieu ça c'est toute la difficulté de
la vie politique c'est que vous pouvez
alors que c'est un non-lieu être
totalement exclue c'est un grand
spécialiste des questions de défense sa
personne personne ne le nie évidemment
aujourd'hui on est en période de toute
façon on est juste avant les prochaines
élections qui re tous les membres du
gouvernement vont être un moment ou à un
autre la cible d'une critique la sig
d'une attaque d'une manière ou d'une
manière ou d'une autre
donc ça c'est une évidence a aussi
partiellement
vous savez l'année dernière j'étais
l'objet d'une rumeur
magnifique donc je m'attends à tout
aujourd'hui vous avez souffert de cette
rumeur
ah oui j'en ai souffert ma famille en a
souffert c'est ça le plus important
j'ai toujours dit que je mangeais les
idées très claires s'il faut que je
renonce à la politique pour ma famille
je le ferai mais c'est pour ça que je
vous dis il ya peu de barrières en
politique qui a peu de limites mais on
touche pas à la famille mardi et pendant
que
monde parle du remaniement françois
hollande lui se déplace sur le terrain
il annoncera sa candidature à la
primaire socialiste après les élections
cantonales
en attendant françois hollande fait
campagne pour se faire connaître des
français il reste encore du travail
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage de bureaux jardin glace loin
de ses terres corréziennes mais tout
près de celle de dominique strauss kahn
c'est en banlieue parisienne que
françois hollande est venu se montrer
aujourd'hui sourire est petite blague
l'ex premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste est à l'aise en campagne ce
que c'est un moyen de rencontrer nos
concitoyens de les entendre de les
comprendre et aussi de se présenter à
eux parce que on peut être connus
parfois par la télévision que l'on doit
rester comme ça loin s'il l'affirment
haut et fort c'est d'abord pour les
cantonales qu'il est là le député de
corrèze est aussi venu pour tester sa
nouvelle popularité et parmi les
socialistes de saint-ouen il a plutôt la
coque
j'aime bien socialiste en fait nous
sommes bien sûr trop longtemps surtout
quand il parle basque est en fait je le
défends au moins un mort à duda
j'aimerais qu'il soit viré et un
jour la france dans la rue en revanche
la plupart connaissent son visage mais
pour son nom il y encore du travail
un sens et une boisson comme freinage
c'est quoi c'est beau boulot boulot
candidat pour les primaires ou par
françois hollande n'en parlera pas
aujourd'hui en tout cas il est en
campagne et ça se voit on entend
beaucoup de ministres de notamment de
députés ou sénateurs ump qu'il faut
monter en ce moment françois hollande en
disant que ce serait le candidat le plus
dangereux pour nicolas sarkozy notamment
c'est une stratégie de l'ump non je
crois pas occupons nous d'abord
d'essayer de nous d'avoir des de faire
des propositions avant d'essayer de
régler le problème du ps
c'est enfin cette semaine c'est
effectivement françois hollande qui fait
la une la semaine dernière c'était dsk
pendant ce temps là martine aubry sort
le programme de 80 bon voilà c'est là
c'est la bataille interne du ps je pense
pas que ce soit une stratégie en général
vous savez quand on fait des stratégies
on se tire toujours des balles dans le
pied donc autant éviter de faire ce
genre de stratégie c'est la sphère du ps
toutes façons ils ont leurs primaires
ils vont ils vont choisir en interne on
n'a pas à s'immiscer dans les affaires
du ps comme on ne comprendrait pas que
le ps s'immisce dans les affaires de
l'ump
ah ben ça c'est une chose françois
hollande était en déplacement pour les
élections cantonales vous ces élections
cantonales c'est pour vous une chronique
d'une défaite annoncée ou pas les
élections cantonales c'est un scrutin
très particulier parce que c'est marrant
d'ailleurs c'est un scrutin quand même
majoritaire uninominal
il ya peu d'élections majoritaire
uninominal c'est donc ce qu'est ce que
tu as très particulier très locale très
très local avec des personnalités qu'en
général on ne connaît pas donc on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui chronique d'une
défaite annoncée
les enjeux nationaux sur ce type de
scrutin sont normalement relativement
faible pourtant on sait que l'ump n'ait
jamais gagnante sur des élections
locales
ça c'est lié à un autre un autre sujet
qui la nécessité d'avoir beaucoup plus
de travail de terrain comme comme à
paris quand je vous dit tout à l'heure
que c'est dès maintenant qu'on doit se
préparer à paris parce qu'on attend
toujours le dernier moment pour décider
que ce sera un candidat providentiel
non c'est on a le même problème partout
il faut travailler très en amont sur le
terrain et c'est pour ça que parfois on
a des difficultés donc ça veut dire que
l'ump ne le fait pas assez sur le
terrain c'est ça il faut qu'on le fasse
beaucoup plus qui a donc il ya souvent
un manque pas c'est souvent ceux faut
qu'on fasse beaucoup plus j'ai vécu
pendant les élections régionales on y va
trop tard on y voit trop tardivement ce
que les gens attendent d'élus locaux
que ce soit des conseillers généraux des
conseillers régionaux et des conseillers
municipaux on le fait mieux d'abord pour
les conseillers municipaux c'est qu'ils
soient constamment présent pour répondre
à leurs préoccupations quotidiennes et
c'est ça d'ailleurs le rôle normalement
un élu vous avez vu ce phénomène qu'on
avait déjà constaté pour les régionales
que les candidats locaux masque au
maximum l'étiquette nationale qu'ils ont
essayé essayé comme je vous le disais en
grande partie au fait que ce sont
vraiment sur des préoccupations locales
que ça que ça se joue qu'on a toujours
cette idée à cacher son appartenance
nationale d'un côté un petit peu m e
bonds en sort vous savez des fois
j'aimerais bien que comme disent qu'ils
cachent vraiment son étiquette parce que
faire une campagne sans parti je leur
souhaite bon courage
je connaissais pas trop en fait me suis
pas végéter pas du tout encartés ump je
connaissais pas la vie politique je les
ai vus pendant les élections régionales
sans l'appui d'un parti l'organisation
et surtout sur les militants vous ne
faites rien donc je pense que ça doit
être très relatif ce genre d'attitude
allez hop assaut mercredi avec un débat
à venir sur la laïcité qui ne suscite
guère d'enthousiasmé y compris à droite
c'est une idée venue de l'ump et plus
précisément de jean françois copé un
débat sur l'islam il aura lieu le 5
avril prochain lors d'une convention de
l'ump avec des propositions à la clé
pour apaiser les inquiétudes de la
majorité l'opération a été rebaptisé
convention sur la laïcité et en ce
mercredi jean françois copé a du mal à
s'en souvenir
gerin germain d'ailleurs le dossier est
ultrasensible mais jean françois copé ne
reculera pas ce matin rue la boétie
face aux médias il tente une nouvelle
fois malgré un lapsus de déminer le
terrain depuis le début il m'a dit ce
n'est pas sur l'islam ce n'est pas sur
la le lille la laïcité comportera un
volet concernant l'organisation de
l'islam de france
on l'a toujours dit et pas question de
modifier le calendrier
le débat aura bien lieu à l'ump le 5
avril
accusé par l'opposition de chasser sur
les terres du front national jean
françois copé car pourtant tout risque
de stigmatisation de l'islam
c'est tout l'inversé tôt au contraire de
soulager
nos compatriotes de confession musulmane
qui en ont ras-le-bol qu'on mélange
qu'on amalgame l'exercice du culte
musulman dans une république laïque avec
des pratiques qui sont celles d'une
extrême minorité qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'exercice du culte musulman
un an après les polémiques du débat sur
l'identité nationale
cette nouvelle initiative est contestée
par l'opposition et au sein même de la
majorité
j'ai entendu des voies très différentes
à l'ump quand par exemple alain juppé
met en garde je partage ces précautions
il est bon de replacer au coeur de la
république les valeurs républicaines la
laïcité et de rappeler que l'islam de
france n'est pas de l'islam en france
comme l'avait dit le président la
république on ne comprend pas la façon
dont nicolas sarkozy essaye alors qu'il
n'y a pas de débat sur la laïcité dans
notre pays alors qu'elle est une valeur
qui est fondamental alors que la
question que se pose tout républicain
c'est de savoir continuez à la faire
vivre le mieux possible de notre pays
mais pour jean françois copé seul compte
le soutien de nicolas sarkozy sur la
laïcité l'elysée exige des propositions
concrètes dans les mois à venir alors
chantal jouanno le débat sur l'islam
devient une convention sur la laïcité de
quoi va-t-on exactement parler le 5
avril on comprend on ne peut parler que
de laïcité sert que de toute façon tout
le monde politique républicain tout
parti républicain donc je vous mets de
côté marine le pen ne doit avoir comme
pour objectif de rassembler la société
tous les débats qui opposent qui crée
des tensions au sein de la société sont
pas des débats républicains ça c'est
vraiment un principe de base qu'il faut
jamais oublier
c'est quelle société on laisse à nos
enfants et cette société ça peut pas
être une société du conflit entre les
uns et les autres
donc ça c'est un premier sujet et c'est
vrai que il ya bouge beaucoup il ya eu
trop de propos qui ont fait des
musulmans un problème c'est donc pas un
problème humain sont l'identité
nationale française par contre il ya un
grand changement par rapport à 1905
on a mis trente ans à voter cette a
décidé sur cette fameuse loi de 1905
effectivement sur la séparation de
l'église et de l'état qui est le fond
dans le souk de ce qu'on appelle la
laïcité aujourd'hui en france
depuis la religion musulmane est devenue
la deuxième religion de france et ses
pratiquants n'ont pas de lieu de culte
suffisant de dire que quand on
s'offusque qu'ils prient dans les rues
mais ils le font pas par plaisir pour
quand il fait froid ou quand il pleut
ils le font parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
lieu de culte adapté développe des arts
on a aussi nous l'obligation et je pense
que ça dans la partie des propositions
c'est un point très important d'apporter
des réponses à ce débat le président en
avril si on comprend bien vous allez
parler laïcité mais vous allez aussi par
les financements des mozart on va parler
pratique du culte pour qu'elle se fasse
la meilleure manière que ce soit le
président de la république c'est quand
même lui qui avait créé le conseil
français du culte musulman
c'est lui qui a parlé aussi de l'aide à
la formation des imams et c'est lui
aussi qui avait posé cette question des
lieux de culte d'avoir des lieux de
culte qui soit digne qui soit à la
hauteur de la deuxième religion de
france
il ya des propositions sur la table il
faut pas les balayer etc il ya un
principe on ne touche pas à la loi de
1905 parce que sinon là on va opposer
les gens ça c'est clair
mais quand à la main que par exemple
propose des solutions de financement
temporaire exceptionnelle vraiment
exceptionnel pour des lieux de culte qui
doivent être des lieux de proximité
d'ailleurs dalil boubakeur le dit très
bien ce qu'on a ce dont on a besoin ce
sont des lieux de proximité
ça c'est une proposition intéressante à
étudier mais vraiment moi je vis pas
dans la même société que marine le pen
et je ne vois pas un problème si chez
tous les personnes qui m'entourent alors
l'ump entend prôner les valeurs de la
laïcité est au même moment nicolas
sarkozy en visite au puy en velay vante
les mérites de la chrétienté et
l'importance de notre héritage chrétien
ce cas pas une petite contradiction non
parce que c'est un président a toujours
dit et c'était d'ailleurs ce qu'il a dit
depuis 2002 c'est ce qu'il allait
rappeler dans son livre que c'est très
important que la religion est important
dans un pays la laïcité ça veut pas dire
le moins de place possible aux religions
il a toujours parlé de l'espérance et
que quand on croit à une religion
qu'elle soit une religion chrétienne ou
une religion musulmane c'est un bon
lumière dans notre vie et ça il a
toujours dit donc quand on fait un pas
vers la religion musulmane on peut aussi
faire un pas vers la religion que l'idée
de mêler les religions au discours
politique ça c'est pas mêler les
religions au discours politique
c'est simplement arrêter de mettre un
voile pudique sur des questions qui sont
des vraies questions parce qu'en même
temps quand marine le pen ni les tiens
t'es où vas pas trop où elle va le voile
pudique sur cette affaire enfin pourquoi
pourquoi exalter ses valeurs chrétiennes
aujourd'hui elle est juste parti elle
son âge est partie de notre patrimoine
de notre culture mais elles ne sont pas
du tout en contradiction avec d'autres
valeurs c'est là ce sont des religion
tolérante ces religions dont on parle ce
sont des religion tolérante
il faut pas l'oublier et les valeurs
chrétiennes de la france qui sont mises
en avant par le président de la
république et maintenant par nathalie
kosciusko morizet vous l'avez peut-être
dans le magazine la vie où elle dit tout
simplement l'écologie et révolutionnaire
comme l'évangile la ministre de
l'ecologie qui affirme que les liens
entre écologie et spiritualité sont
multiples pour vous les valeurs
religieuses et l'écologie 'ça va de pair
c'est normal de pouvoir
j'ai re c'est le ministre puisse mettre
en avant ses valeurs morales on va dire
chaque ministre un droit d'avoir ses
propres ses propres convictions
maintenant on agit pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens quelles que soient leurs
convictions qu'il faut jamais faut
jamais donner le sentiment que l'on fait
ça dans un sens qui serait le sens de
religion et pas d'une autre
j'ai pas lu son interview j'ai pas lu
son interview l'écologie s'intéresse à
l'homme le fondement même de l'écologie
c'est l'homme comme toutes les religions
donc il ya toujours un lien évidemment
mais ceci dit je dis kosciusko morizet
quand elle dit l'écologie est
révolutionnaire comme l'évangile que je
fonderai subirait pas l'écologie au seul
évangiles voilà parce que effectivement
après quelqu'un d'autre va pouvoir vous
dire que c'est révolutionnaire comme la
torah c'est révolutionnaire bon voilà
c'est pas comme toute religion
mélanger la religion avec l'écologie ça
paraît quand même assez étrange
c'est assez loin entre les deux oui bon
ça c'est moi entre les deux là vous
allez un peu dévié dû dévier du débat
mais mais l'écologie pose des questions
de valeurs et des questions de société
comme la religion pose des questions de
valeurs maintenant j'aurai pas fait le
lien avec une religion particulière
parce qu'on travaille pour tous les
français quelles que soient leurs
convictions
donc ya pas d'erreur de nathalie
kosciusko morizet j'aime trop nathalie
pour critiquer ma taille alors pour en
revenir à des à des dérapages possibles
là on n'est plus vraiment les religions
mais dans l'identité nationale vous avez
vu sans doute l'accueil réservé par les
députés de la majorité au chroniqueur
eric zemmour cette semaine eric zemmour
condamné pour injure raciale et qui est
venu à l'assemblée pour participer à un
colloque sans doute paru mots il a
notamment dit qu'on pourrait supprimer
les subventions aux associations
antiracistes le plus surprenant
peut-être ont été les applaudissements
des députés qui ont suivi
dérapage selon vous moi je cautionne pas
du tout ce que dit eric zemmour parce
qu'on ne peut pas dire d'un côté on
accepte d des propos à caractère raciste
de d'eric zemmour et le refuser quand ce
sont des chanteurs de rap ou d'autres
qui rit faut être un peu cohérent avec
nos avec laval hier à l'assemblée dans
une rame de la mort de députés de la
majorité
accueillir dans une réunion eric zemmour
d'autres personnes qui sont des
provocateurs c'est pas grave ça avant
soit à la limite le débat doit être
ouvert à tout le monde et tout le monde
a droit d'avoir ses convictions il
construit un provocateur condamné pour
injure ainsi compris un provocateur qui
conserve qui reste quand même
journalistes qui continuent
il n'a pas été bien et que je sache donc
oui il peut être il peut être accueillis
après ce que l'on pense de ces proposé
sur ça c'est autre chose et ça je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la question
et en plus il est même pas drôle quoi
c'est pas un humoriste c'est un
journaliste bon mais ce qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'on pense de la question du racisme
et des discriminations c'est devenu une
question très sensible dans notre
société
voilà les choses ont changé on peut plus
dire des choses qu'on pouvait dire il ya
30 ans c'est terminé ça donc non je
cautionne pas ce que dit eric zemmour
pas du tout parce que je pense que le
un sujet central en ce moment c'est le
vivre ensemble un sujet absolument
central et d'apaiser effectivement ces
questions dans notre quotidien des
députés à sa proposition qui comme
ulysse n'est même pas drôle ça vous
inspire quoi
chacun est libre de penser ce qu'il veut
c'est ça la politique
on va passer à l'économie et jeudi
notamment le gouvernement qui a dévoilé
ses pistes sur la réforme de la
fiscalité
c'était une intervention très attendue
lors d'un colloque à bercy françois
fillon ce jeudi présente les nouvelles
tendances de la fiscalité 2012
c'est maintenant certain le bouclier
fiscal mesure phare du quinquennat
sarkozy va disparaître en contrepartie
l'impôt sur la fortune sera allégée pour
les contribuables les moins aisés
concernés par lisf les explications de
chloé buffard sans surprise françois
fillon a confirmé la fin du bouclier
fiscal mesure phare du début de mandat
de nicolas sarkozy le bouclier fiscal a
été mal compris et sans doute la crise
que nous avons traversée at elle rendu
nos concitoyens plus sensibles à
certains de ses effets en supprimant le
bouclier fiscal nous voulons en même
temps supprimer les raisons qui avaient
rendu nécessaire son instauration
et donc nous voulons mettre fin aux
défauts de l'isf dont le bouclier était
le remède imparfait
le premier ministre a ensuite esquissé
les pistes de réforme de liesse f une
seule certitude pour l'instant les
français seront taxées à partir d'un
million trois cent mille euros de
patrimoine contre huit cent mille euros
aujourd'hui le seuil de l' isf sera donc
relevé il n'est pas question de toucher
au livret a à l'assurance vie du petit
épargnant ni à aucun des placements des
ménages qui ne sont pas à l'isf
aujourd'hui je veux le dire
solennellement devant vous cette réforme
ne les mettra en aucune façon à
contribution
en revanche elle devrait permettre de
sortir de l'imposition sur la fortune
les 300 mille foyers qui y sont entrés
depuis dix ans essentiellement à
cause de la flambée des prix de
l'immobilier le gouvernement va-t-il
seulement allégé lisf nicolas sarkozy
souhaiterait une réforme plus radicale
la suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
problème il faudrait trouver près de 4
milliards d'euros pour compenser un
casse tête en période de déficits
budgétaires alors chantal jouanno la
suppression du bouclier fiscal l'a quand
même fait dire que nicolas sarkozy a été
contraint il y a alors il a été
contraint parce que à l'origine on
n'avait pas voulu retouché lisf et
notamment les défauts de l'usf bouclier
fiscal on n'avait pas voulu on a on
s'est glissé en fait dans un livre
positif de bouclier fiscal qui
préexistait ce que vous souvenez qu'il a
été créée d'abord à 70% ensuite abaissée
à 60% il était passé à 50%
donc c'est pour pas touché sur le fond
du sf que la voie du bouclier fiscal
avait été en effet la sarkozy disait on
ne touche pas au bouclier fiscal ce qui
ce que souhaite le président c'est assez
simple c'est d'éviter effectivement que
l'imposition sur la fortune qui est
nécessaire est nécessaire il s'agit de
taxer ceux qui gagnent énormément
d'argent ne dissuade tout ce qui est
investissements productifs emploi
travaillent donc ça c'est assez logique
et ça c'est pas critiquable donc cette
nouvelle réforme en fait son objectif
c'est effectivement d'être plus juste et
d'éviter que ceux qui ont des très
grosses fortunes échappe à une forme de
taxation et qu'en même temps ceux qui
ont finalement peu d'argent mais qui ont
un patrimoine qui a pris beaucoup de
valeur parce que l'immobilier explosent
et malheureusement dans notre pays que
cela se trouve taxés en plus juste et en
même temps plus efficaces donc pour
éviter cette injuste l'ouvrier le
bouclier fiscal était en tout cas perçue
comme injuste ça c'est clair parce que
c'était conçu comme un chèque qu'on veut
donner à des personnes qui gagnent trop
d'argent donc ça a été perçu ça a été
perçu comme ça mais ça avait une vraie
logique économique savez une vraie
logique qui était d'éviter effectivement
que tout investissement productif tout
ce qui favorise l'emploi ne pas je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le vrai débat de fond il
est peut-être beau plus là dessus
d'ailleurs c'est que est ce que on taxe
beaucoup plus le travail que le capital
c'est vraiment beaucoup de pays mais
c'est vrai en france
une taxe beaucoup plus le travail que
les dividendes c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi j'étais pour la taxe
carbone parce que je préfère contacter
la pollution et je reste convaincu qu'il
est fâché avec le président latino tôt
et je suis pas fâché avec le préfixe et
au président j'ai juste mes convictions
et je les garde
juste un petit bout une anecdote à jean
reno l'acteur l'un des mieux payés de
france lui il serait prêt à partir en
suisse parce qu'on supprime le bouclier
fiscal et c'est le cas aussi par exemple
des sportifs français les aime peut-être
les chocolats non je puis plus
sérieusement on en a parlé récemment
d'ailleurs avec avec amélie mauresmo
quelques sportifs que génère énormément
parce qu'en plus elle est très belle et
très sereine et c'est vrai que pour les
sportifs la difficulté qu'ils ont c'est
qu'ils ont des carrières entre 8 et 10
ans et pendant ces carrières là ils
payent énormément énormément d'impôts et
après ils gagnent beaucoup moins
d'argent donc leurs difficultés elle est
là maintenant aujourd'hui dans ce
contexte actuel je ne vois pas mettre en
place un dispositif spécifique pour les
sportifs de ça c'est dit que les
sportifs un petit mot pour conclure du
sénat l'ump de se trouver un nouveau
président de groupe ce sera le quatrième
en trois ans c'est un poste stratégique
car l'ump ne dispose pas de la majorité
absolue
alors qui pour remplacer gérard longuet
devenu ministre l'un des forces
les réponses de fabrice qu'une et de
qualité au delà des hommes est derrière
les sourires l'ump a surtout beaucoup de
courants différents
à commencer par le très influent
territoires et républiques menée par
jean pierre raffarin
c'est un moment important pour le coup
rien d'exagéré
pourtant l'ancien premier ministre mais
la pression depuis dimanche pour que ces
proches pèse dans cette élection à la
tête de l'ump
je pense qu'il est très important que au
sein du groupe ump du sénat on n'oublie
pas de faire valoir justement ce courant
humaniste qui me paraît au moins aussi
important que le courant de la droite
populaire qui s'exprime beaucoup
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale le
message est pour jean claude gaudin
mardi matin il confirme sa candidature à
la présidence du groupe
le sénateur-maire de marseille sait
qu'il peut compter sur une large
majorité question d'expérience et
d'échéances électorales aussi on
approche dès les sénatoriales élections
sénatoriales vous le savez au mois de
septembre et jean claude gaudin a une
connaissance parfaite du territoire et
de mode
l'élection des sénateurs tout le
problème est d'éviter une lutte
fratricide au sein du groupe en pleine
campagne des cantonales et à quelques
mois de ses sénatoriales cruciales le
j'essaie de trouver bien entendu un
rapprochement avec monsieur raffarin sur
le plan des idées rien de nous sépare
c'est simplement quelquefois bon la
volonté pour monsieur raffarin de faire
avancer tel ou tel de ses amis proches
les deux hommes sont finalement parvenus
à un accord jean pierre raffarin
récupère la place de vice président du
sénat occupé par jean claude gaudin car
seul candidat le sénateur maire de
marseille est sûre de succéder à gérard
longuet mardi à lui d'attribuer ensuite
les sièges de vice-président du groupe
en ménageant les différentes composantes
de l'ump chantal jouanno a entendu jean
pierre raffarin qui prône le
renouvellement des générations est ce
que jean claude gaudin c'est le meilleur
candidat pour le sénat c'est surtout un
homme de dialogue c'est celui qui s'est
le mieux rassembler les uns et les
autres dans toute leur sensibilité
donc oui meilleur candidat jean claude
gaudin bah oui pour en tant qu homme de
dialogue et pour rassembler les uns les
uns et les autres
aujourd'hui nous sommes qu'ils soient
politiques aussi par la politique à
marseille n'est pas une ville facile on
avait bien de l'ambiance quand même
entre jean-pierre raffarin et jean
claude guillon dans le juge apolitique
pour terminer on vous a proposé à
semble-t-il un poste de sénatrice pour
septembre 2011 vous avez dit c'est une
proposition qu'on ne refuse pas vous
êtes toujours partante
toujours partante à l'investiture à
l'investissement comme cheminement oui
parce que j'ai fait mon premier débat au
sénat
et j'aime beaucoup la manière de
travailler que cette assemblée puis
j'aime bien le temps donc vous y voyez
en septembre 2011 on verra ça d'ici là
c'est toujours des chemins qui sont
assez longs comme toute forme d'élection
et paris may 14 ici on peut vous
peut-être pouvoir aussi sur candidature
c'est imaginable de vous voir pour
l'ambition de paris aux municipales
comme mr donc avec un ticket avec atik
avec le prochain candidat à la mairie il
faut vraiment quelqu'un d'expérimenté de
beaucoup plus capé comme on dit mais en
tout cas pour aider oui donc la position
sur le travail de fond j'aime bien c'est
ça et la politique toujours oui vous
êtes toujours partie pour pour continuer
à priori un autre ministère ça vous
ferait plaisir
après avoir fait développement durable
écologie dès son arrivée vous ne posait
déjà la question de la suite s'est
jamais dans sa survie honnêtement je
suis jusqu'à 2012 ça fait 18 mois au
total
c'est le minimum pour pouvoir mener une
action sur 1 sur un ministre il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire au sport il
ya vraiment beaucoup de choses lutte
contre la corruption poursuite de la
lutte contre le dopage
l'intégration par le sport les jeunes
filles dans les quartiers notamment est
absolument prioritaire donc il n'ya pas
de quoi s'ennuyer
et bien c'est sur ces paroles que nous
allons nous quitte et chantal jouanno
merci à vous d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter l'actualité de la semaine et
nous michael ne retrouveront la semaine
prochaine
même lieu même heure bonne semaine au
revoir au revoir